okay we are live so i am here with uh
with jen
we're working on her movement which is
fantasy now you guys may have seen jen
from some of the other stuff we've been
doing
uh the one-on-one coaching helping her
build her business we're kind of
switching directions and focusing on her
movement which is fantasy
so jen do you want to give everybody
watching a quick
fantasy intro what fantasy fantasy is
all about
yeah sure so um i just love uh to
fantasize
and i think it's a really great way to
get the things in your life that you
want
and i encourage everyone to have
fantasies
and be fearless about it don't be afraid
of what your fantasies are
because i think that they really um you
know tell a lot about who you are and
they can bring you closer to other
people if you share them
and if you write them down um you know
uh
words make it real that's my that's my
little tagline so um and i use fantasy
in my copy because i
think it um uh really taps into people's
dreams and desires and it really helps
um you know you know make the bridge
between what
product you're selling and what their
fantasies are and helps make their
fantasies come true
i like it so you know when we first
i had an issue with fantasy in in
making it connect to me that is that has
started
coming through better and i think this
is going to be
um a challenge in that
okay when we first started talking and
it's definitely over it's definitely
solvable
when we first started talking about
fantasy um
it seemed a little what uh like airy
like
um uh okay you know like not important
enough like whimsical
right right whimsical not important
enough
and and now this is important because
we're trying to build a movement so you
have to get people to care about
this word and and what you wrote in the
copy
helped bring it home a little bit better
for me
so you were talking about you know
fantasies are your dreams
and not to be afraid of them
right right you could share the right
people
and then to write them down those are
the three things right
yep and to not limit yourself to what's
that
and to not limit yourself not limit
yourself because i think a lot of
yeah i think a lot of people like don't
realize like they can fantasize about
anything that they want right it doesn't
necessarily mean it's going to come true
but have a fantasy right i mean
i think you could you can have it
anywhere anytime you can access your
families whenever you want and they can
really change your mindset i mean you
know i think
if you think about people who have been
in the darkest you know horrors of their
life they probably were able to get
through it because the fantasies and
and were where their head was what they
were able to imagine
you know and so i think it can help you
know bring all the pleasure to your life
as well as really help you
um during your dark times so it's don't
don't be afraid of them right don't
worry that they're too crazy
unconventional
don't limit exactly and then
share them and write them down i guess
share them and write them down are those
are they similar yeah they are similar
but they're a little different because
you can share with somebody and it can
really bring you closer to that person
and um and that gives you like an
instant ally someone who really can help
you bring that fantasy come true but
then also writing them down the process
of writing them down
and being able to read the words really
makes it real like if you can feel it
you know you can see it on the page
there in front of you you can imagine it
more and it really makes it more real
for you
right so i think
what you have to do here now is start
thinking about
you're going to have two groups of
people you're going to have the hardcore
people who will love everything you do
who are like you say fantasy to them and
they're like yeah they're on board right
away they get it
and you're going to have the fringe who
don't quite get it
who need to be need to understand it
uh yeah and getting those people in to
become part of a hardcore
group well right now we don't have a
hardcore group so we're
we're building that it's good it's okay
sometimes you feel
talking to yourself um i know
so i think if we're just using
the word fantasy and using your tagline
like words make it real it's good to
reinforce the message
but it's not meaningful to the new
people who just look at it and they
think fantasy is
more the whimsical
not okay all right yeah but what you
just talked about
was really important and can touch
everybody so that's what fantasy means
to you
which is really powerful and is a really
big idea
i had the same thing believe where uh
most people think i think believe is
maybe a little bit easier to understand
but
most people think believe is just
believe in yourself
well for me it's a lot right it's
believe that you're doing the right
thing
so finding your past doing something
you're passionate about
and then believe that it'll work out so
believe that even though you're doing
things and you you just see darkness
that it's still right like me right now
with fancy right
and so you know when people come
they think of believe as one thing but
to me it's way more and so i have to
i don't just explain it to them and you
know welcome everybody and here's what
exactly what it means to me but
in the post that i share in the content
i create it touches on all three of
those
important things to me so
we got to do the same thing for fantasy
so it's
you're touching on pain points here
right so somebody has
a fantasy a dream but it's too you know
that's that's too crazy or i could never
do that or
you know right like that's that's
exactly right
limiting beliefs right if you're
touching on limiting personal beliefs
then it becomes powerful so the content
that you create should touch on the
limiting personal beliefs
around fantasy what fantasy can help
solve
okay yeah
so the fantasy word itself
will start to make more it'll have
meaning to be and people look at my
stuff and i hashtag
believe and like what what is what's
going on right but
right followers other people now will
hashtag believe on stuff
even though believe isn't in the
sentence
that's being shared or in the picture
but it represents the idea
and so that's where we create yes
fantasies that it represents this idea
of
of what fantasy means and so
the posts that you share don't
necessarily have to have the word
fantasy
in it yeah they'll embody
fantasy or what it means to you okay
right the seat is because that's kind of
where i'm trapped
i i maybe i can load up your recent
tweets let me see if i can find some
yeah you're right i mean i do use
fantasy a lot in the words and i found
i've found i've you know done a little
searching and found some really cool
examples
that other people have used fantasy but
for the most part yeah the word fantasy
is in there or i just
add it in there and then you know post
something that's related
right and so uh different people will
have different
understandings of the word like i look
at believe there's tons of
justin bieber has an album called
believe right
right believers the believers
a lot of right people use beliefs
like i believe in god i believe in
whoever right
so that's not my meaning i have a
different meaning so i'm creating my own
definition for what belief is to me
that's what i'm sharing that's the
movement i'm creating
and so the same fantasy there's gonna be
a lot of different
views on what fantasy is and so yeah
every quote with fantasy is not gonna be
your fantasy it's not going to be part
of the fantasy movement
right it makes sense so there was one it
does make sense
yeah in fact there's been some there's
been some you know i mean like i
mentioned to you before like there's
been a lot of posts on twitter about
like fantasy football or fantasy sports
right right i rarely
i rarely repost those because they're
not relevant to what i'm all about
right so
what we need to get to because you're
using twitter which is great we need you
don't have your facebook page set up yet
right
no i don't i need to get that set up
yeah and i started to set up a pinterest
page too but i haven't posted anything
so um yeah but i i need to get those two
going
okay at least the facebook because now
we're tracking it so we got to get that
going
yes definitely
what you need to post
are things that make you feel
gets your heart going right like one eye
yes on fantasy you know for me
i'm not the judge it should be you like
if you read those hundred words you say
yes
um that's what i'm talking about you get
excited
then then you've done a good job
right right yeah and so the same thing
should happen with your tweets
even if it doesn't always make sense to
everybody as long as it
makes you feel yes i love that
uh right sometimes i get the sense that
you're tweeting
just to have something up but doesn't
necessarily
hit you and i could be wrong my judgment
um what was one about uh
i was trying to look back on something
so i had a problem so you had you had a
shakespeare one right lovers and mad men
have such
sweet brains such shaping fantasies that
apprehend more than cool reason could
ever comprehend
maybe i'm just a guy i don't know
but i love that quote i love that quote
i
totally that one really speaks to me
good
then keep it keep it
you need to have stuff that speaks to
you right so
it does it's not going to speak to
everybody and with shakespeare in the
old english it may be hard for people to
digest
um but sure but if you feel it
then post it not just because it has the
word fantasy in it but because it means
something
important okay yeah what i would add on
top of that
is
your advice your
you know what's wrong with the world and
what's your solution
fantasy and we've already talked about
it right this stuff that you talked
about about
being fearless not judging not judging
what your friends
are not limiting yourself
that vein at least speaks to me
i think we'll speak to the audience but
hasn't
fully come out in
the september okay yeah that makes sense
they like
something like you know um don't judge
your dreams
you can do anything you want hashtag
fantasy
right okay that's fantasy to you but
we're not using fantasy necessarily in
the sentence like not everywhere
if you look at what i tweet not
everything i say has believed in it even
though it still
is it all it's all believed for me and
it's all believed for the audience
when it's right right he has to say
believe in the sentence because then you
could be struggling you're sitting like
i gotta find another fantasy quote gotta
find another fantasy quote
so the stuff that you share should
educate people and make them think like
i want to read
your stuff or see your video
and it makes me think okay
so like write down fantasy and see your
truth
words make it real that's a great
message
for it's a great reminder message
for the people who are it's not i
understand fantasy and i understand what
words make it real
that's a great message for me but for a
general
person they're not gonna understand it
right i hear what you're saying yes
right so you need both
you're just posting only for like the
hardcore audience
yeah well we don't have a hardcore
right exactly
which is fine which is fine and and i
know
this was hard for me too because that it
makes sense to you
because that's what you live and breathe
yeah exactly because i'm super
passionate about it and it's funny
because it's even hard for me sometimes
to put it into words you know and here i
am the copywriter but
it's hard to like sort of explain like
why so passionate you know until i just
like
you know start like you know spatting
about it or like that email i sent you
you know that was just more like you
know unedited
i was like okay yeah that makes sense
now i just gotta like find that like you
said find what it is about it makes my
my blood going yeah and and that
i don't know what your writing process
is but that may be the best thing to do
is just write something unedited down or
record something
just something that you get excited
about and and maybe that
involves another person and not the
actual person there but
just thinking about another person a lot
of times when i'm writing something i'm
thinking of
somebody i might be thinking of you or
somebody another entrepreneur
and i'm trying to give advice and i get
passionate about something so i'll start
writing and then i could turn
that unedited you know
into actionable so like so for example
i have a i have a newsletter and i have
a twitter feed
and uh and facebook and all that and my
newsletter
is a is a long post i don't know if
you're on my list or not but
right the long post i am on your list
and it's uh it's
edited by me and it's no it doesn't go
to anybody else
but it's still i try to keep it raw and
something that i feel is important and
needs to be shared
right and then from there i'll take
some of the most powerful sentences that
i enjoy and turn them into quotes that
can go on facebook
and go on to twitter so you're okay
you're i mean you don't have a
newsletter yet but you can imagine like
you're writing a letter to somebody
you're trying to give them advice on
fantasy
yeah yeah right and then you take some
of the most powerful sentences
and then you can turn it into a tweet a
day for a week or a facebook post a day
for a week so you only write one i like
that
yeah i mean and that could be a blog
post maybe instead of doing a newsletter
newsletter do a blog post uh yeah i was
just gonna say i i
i want to start doing my blog post once
a week so that's a great idea just to
take
lines from that and use it in my other
things that's a great it's a fantastic
idea
i love it saving time yeah
absolutely it's good i mean and those
could be launching points for youtube
videos
it could be launching points for um yeah
people launching boards for clients
coming and finding you and say wow i
really like what you wrote about this
and i have a
project and i'm looking at what i'm
writing and it's total crap
and i want to incorporate this um you
know you may need to tweak a few of the
sentences to shorten it down
or make it more impactful but um
that's probably a good place to start
yeah
so if you're if you're starting with a
blog you write one blog post a week
that that is meaningful to you that
that encapsulates i would pick one topic
pick one theme so if we're
let's see what i want to do so being
fearless
it's gonna be fearless right your blog
post is called be fearless
and then you talk about whatever that
means to you because that's still
fantasy
even though it's not about writing down
your fantasies
right your one topic is be fearless the
whole post is about being fearless if
it's
300 words 500 words 2 000 words whatever
you know i don't usually put a word
count on what i'm writing
it's more right this is what i have to
say
and now i'm done whatever right
i'm the same i'm the same okay so
each of those points right being
fearless
other ones don't judge yourself or
another one you're not crazy
right they're all like yeah those are
painful
limiting personal beliefs that people
have that you can help them bust through
through your lens of fantasy
yeah and then you could take the top
sentences from each one of those
and post it to twitter post it to
facebook and hashtag
fantasy right okay
yeah i dig that yeah i i'm exactly
excited to read that stuff
because your words are making it real
for me
yeah yeah i know that totally makes
sense i and i love that idea because
there's so many things
i could relate to the things that i'm
passionate about in
like my hundred words like you were
saying i love that yeah
and then when you get to like if you do
a series of posts like that
when you get to something like share
your fantasy
it's for people who've been reading a
lot it's easier to understand
and you may not have to substitute like
fantasy with dream or something like
that you can you can keep it
and then the whole post on why it's
important to share but
yeah why you need to share your dream
your fantasy with
with a friend right and then you can
tell a story like i really wanted to do
this project but i was scared about it
and i wasn't sure
how to go about it and then i shared it
with somebody like well now i got to do
it i'm committed and it was amazing
or like tell me a personal story to tie
it all together
and then you can break that out into
twitter and facebook
sure right and there's a lot of
different things i could relate to
telling just sharing a story with
somebody too
sorry to interrupt you there no no it's
good it's great to include personal
examples yeah and keep it
narrowly focused where this is a big
challenge
a lot i mean i read your blog so i'm not
i'm not judging yours but just in
general people try to cover tons of
different things like here
the 10 things you need to do and then
you forget everything
right summarize we tend to summarize
so if i'm telling a story you know i
could say
yeah i'm my first business i was making
500 bucks a month and then
that was really painful uh and then you
know i landed this big deal and it saved
my company about you know
it's summarizing like put me there
make me feel this one thing right like
500 bucks some i was eating beans for
lunch every day
thinking that like my time is being
wasted and i'm i'm way better than this
like what's happening why am i not
achieving more success dig deep into it
make me feel what you are feeling
and i know you get a copywriter um this
is what you try to do with your clients
but when you're talking sure but
when you talk about fantasy break it
down into
narrow but go deep make me feel
something with each pose
so sharing like why people can't share
why people are afraid of sharing
why you were afraid of sharing something
a personal story
be vulnerable let me experience it with
you and then how you came up on the
other side
and you loved it and you're so happy
and you still might be scared every time
you do it but you know it's gonna pay
off and so you keep doing it right like
showing that you're
afraid helps people mm-hmm i'm still
fortunate right
right because they're afraid too they're
afraid yeah
i did a story i did a video not too long
ago i don't think it's come live yet but
um before uh before i have a call
with someone who i don't know or before
i do a presentation or before i do a
radio show
i get nervous and i secretly hope
that they're gonna cancel on me like i
did
i have my radio show and i secretly hope
that they're going to email me and say
oh everyone we have like a technical
issue it's not on today oh
good great i i didn't really i don't
know why like
constantly this is in my personality
but then once it starts it's amazing and
then afterwards i feel
so amazing for what just happened and
the people i helped and the message
i love it and so like all right i don't
know why i don't know if you have an
answer maybe i need to talk to a
psychologist i don't know what it is
um but so like sharing that story
people can relate to it not everybody
but a lot of people can relate to it
but it's pushing through pushing through
that limiting
personal belief right and so like same
thing
and you're so personable you come across
so well um
i think people are really warm warm to
you if you can tell those deep
personal stories yeah
yeah no i like that idea a lot
good absolutely yeah and in fact yeah i
recently
did a blog post actually just posted
this morning i i started it a while ago
when i finally posted it
one of the things that i did on there
was i um i also put a little
fantasy story at the beginning of the
post so that way there's
kind of like a little something to kind
of help make them feel something
the story on its own and that sort of
was related to the post too
and then i told my own personal story
hopefully they can relate to it and and
but i love that idea of going a lot
deeper
with one with one subject over and over
and telling different stories around
that one subject
yeah and because i think that would
really help spread my message a little
bit more and
focus me a little bit more on what i'm
really passionate about
yeah and what it means what i mean
fantasy i guess was
always obvious to you but it wasn't
super obvious
to me and other people who are paying
attention so
that helps that helps make it real
yeah yeah exactly makes it real
yeah my words will make it real i love
it
they will they will that's awesome yeah
and you're right
i mean many many people that i've told
the word fantasy too are like
what like they are so confused there's
so many different connotations around
fantasy but for me fantasy
like you said it just makes total sense
i mean it's just like you know
it it implies you know your desires and
your dreams and a desire
it implies like pleasure like you know
like things that you really really want
i don't know it's just
like i'm super excited about it so yeah
i think it um
yeah a word like this dreams is a lot
easier to digest yeah
but it doesn't imply it's different
though because it's like oh it works
different no no it is different i'm not
saying switch to dreams
yeah oh i know you're not i know you're
people to digest
so and that's part of it like
dream is a part of fantasy for you but
fantasy is more than that
right so it's the same yes exactly
self-confidence is a part of belief but
it's only a part
i believe is a lot more for me but it's
a
believing in yourself is that is the
easy digestible component of believe
for people to tag onto my brain the
belief that you're doing the
thing is a little more
complex requires people to tag along a
little more so
like the dreaming thing you make you
might use dreams and fantasy
uh as your way to get in for people
people to understand what you're doing
and to be interested and excited and
then you can hook them in on all the
other
harder to digest things
yeah yeah that that makes sense
absolutely
okay i'm excited so homework we're going
to get
yes that up facebook page set up yep
good the fan page not a personal one
right the fan page the brand
yes yes exactly yeah i have my own
personal facebook page but yeah
the brand page yes okay and then uh
you're gonna write
a blog post a week yep
and then take the top quotes
so the way so the blog post a week is
focused on one topic at a time
and you're gonna take the top quotes and
put it at the twitter and facebook
love it i'm digging it
i'm digging it i'm gonna be following
along i'm gonna be
awesome leads coming out
okay that's great very cool um so you
can
i mean you have the tool you can set up
another time and then for next month
and uh and if you have questions you
want me to look at anything in between
just uh shoot me an email and i'm gonna
follow up on twitter okay good
i'll be tweeting you okay oh sorry one
of the things
about how to find your fantasy that was
genuine that wasn't like
that was me struggling so
that could be another post like how to
find your fantasy
okay that's like makes more sense to me
but
uh you i think you kind of struggled and
answering the question
yeah i'm still like well yeah it was
like like what happened
like that was his feeling that's exactly
what i was thinking i was like how
but you know what's so funny is i had
that thought i was like how do you not
know how to find a fantasy right just
close your eyes and
imagine but it was so funny because i
was thinking i think he's serious like i
think he like i heard that
at first i was like
so you have to you have to uh
walk people through like that could be a
good series
or at least post because i get i get
asked too
a lot by one of the most popular
questions i get asked by entrepreneurs
is how do i find my passion
like how do you know what my passion is
like i feel so sad for you you don't
know what your passion
but that's the number one question i get
asked so people will ask you how do i
find my fantasy
and it's yeah like to do it's obvious
but
that's why it's your word it's easy for
you so you have to make it easy
for other people to get to that space
too so just another idea for blog post
i love it maybe i'll use that one next
week all right
all right i'll read it thanks okay cool
i'll tweet you about it all right thank
you evan good to see you
all right